This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. There have been tens of thousands of deaths as results of the coronavirus pandemic. All have been tragic, but there are two people in particular that we've lost to COVID that were part of the world of architecture and design that we want to honor with a couple of stories today. First, we are mourning the loss of architect Michael McKinnell, along with Gerhard Coleman, McKinnell designed the unforgettable Boston City Hall, completed in 1968. They won the commission for Boston City Hall after submitting their brutalist heroic monument in a contest when Michael McKinnell was just 26 years old.
这里是《99%隐形》。我是罗曼·马尔斯。新冠疫情导致了数以万计的人死亡。每一例都令人悲痛，但我们失去的两位与建筑和设计界相关的人士，特别值得我们今天通过几个故事来纪念。首先，我们悼念建筑师迈克尔·麦金内尔（Michael McKinnell）的离世。麦金内尔与格哈德·卡尔曼（Gerhard Kallmann）共同设计了1968年落成的、令人难忘的波士顿市政厅。在迈克尔·麦金内尔年仅26岁时，他们凭借提交的粗野主义英雄式纪念碑设计方案，赢得了波士顿市政厅的竞标。
It was always a controversial structure. Much of the public fended ugly and too unconventional, but architects and critics tend to love it. This is often the case with brutalism more generally, and that is the subject of a piece, starring Boston City Hall that Avery Chalfenman reported for us back in 2015. To celebrate Michael McKinnell's life, we're gonna play that story for you now. It's one of my favorites. I hope you like it. The best James Bond is either Sean Connery
这始终是一座充满争议的建筑。公众大多觉得它丑陋且过于非传统，但建筑师和评论家却往往对它情有独钟。粗野主义建筑通常都是如此，这也是艾弗里·特鲁夫曼（Avery Truffleman）在2015年为我们报道的、以波士顿市政厅为主角的专题节目的主题。为了纪念迈克尔·麦金内尔的一生，我们现在将为您重播那个故事。这是我最喜欢的节目之一。希望你们也会喜欢。最好的詹姆斯·邦德要么是肖恩·康纳利，
or Daniel Craig. I lean towards Daniel Craig. The new movies are just better. But the Sean Connery films definitely had the best villains. There's Blowfeld of course, who's so iconic that he turned the act of cat stroking into a thing that super villains do. But Bond's flashiest nemesis has to be Goldfinger. Do you expect me to talk?
要么是丹尼尔·克雷格。我更倾向于丹尼尔·克雷格。新电影确实拍得更好。但肖恩·康纳利时期的电影绝对拥有最棒的反派。当然还有布洛菲尔德（Blofeld），他太经典了，以至于他抚摸猫的动作成了超级反派的标配。但邦德最耀眼的宿敌一定是金手指（Goldfinger）。你指望我开口说话吗？
No, Mr. Bond, I expect you to die! Do you expect me to talk? Yeah, I expect you to talk. There's this dorky fun fact that the Bond villain Goldfinger was actually named after a real person. That's truffle-me. Avery truffle-me. The author of the James Bond books, In Fleming, named Goldfinger for a man he found so
不，邦德先生，我指望你去死！你指望我开口说话吗？是的，我指望你开口说话。有一个关于邦德反派“金手指”的冷知识，那就是这个名字其实源于一个真实的人。那是特鲁夫曼，艾弗里·特鲁夫曼。詹姆斯·邦德系列小说的作者伊恩·弗莱明（Ian Fleming）以一个他认为非常
dastardly, so terrible that he immortalized him in pop culture. The real gold finger was an architect, Erno Goldfinger, and he made giant, hulking, austere, concrete buildings. Goldfinger's buildings were decreed sole-less, inhabitants claimed to suffer health problems and depression from spending time inside them. Some of Goldfinger's buildings were vacated because occupants found them so ugly. And yet many architects praised Goldfinger buildings were vacated because occupants found them so ugly. And yet many architects praised Goldfingers buildings. His trellic tower, which was once threatened with demolition, has been awarded landmark status. This divide, this hatred from the public and love from designers and architects, tends to be the narrative around buildings like gold fingers, which is to say gigantic, imposing buildings made of concrete.
卑鄙、非常糟糕的人的名字命名了“金手指”，并将他永载于流行文化之中。真正的“金手指”是一位建筑师，埃尔诺·戈德芬格（Erno Goldfinger），他建造了巨大、笨重、严峻的混凝土建筑。戈德芬格的建筑被斥为“没有灵魂”，住户声称因身处其中而遭受健康问题和抑郁症的困扰。戈德芬格的一些建筑因为住户觉得太丑而被弃用。然而，许多建筑师却赞美戈德芬格的建筑。他的特雷利克塔（Trellick Tower）曾一度面临拆除威胁，但后来被授予了地标建筑地位。这种分歧——公众的憎恨与设计师和建筑师的喜爱——往往是围绕像戈德芬格这类建筑的叙事主题，也就是说，那些由混凝土建造的巨大、宏伟的建筑。
What some people refer to as brutalist architecture. And a lot of folks, beyond the creator of James Bond, love to hate them. We are in Worcester Hall, which to my great-dismay illustration is often considered the worst building on campus, or Worcester Hall, more like Worst. I met up with Sarah Briggs Ramsey in Worcester Hall, a brutalist building at UC Berkeley. I can't tell you how many times I've been locking up my bike outside and I over here undergrads,
也就是有些人所说的粗野主义建筑。除了詹姆斯·邦德的创作者之外，很多人都喜欢讨厌它们。我们现在在伍斯特大厅（Worcester Hall），令我非常沮丧的是，它通常被认为是校园里最糟糕的建筑，或者说“伍斯特大厅”更像是“最差大厅”。我在伍斯特大厅见到了莎拉·布里格斯·拉姆齐（Sarah Briggs Ramsey），这是加州大学伯克利分校的一座粗野主义建筑。我数不清有多少次在外面锁自行车时，听到本科生们
walking with their parents, and going, ironically, this is the architecture school and it's the ugliest building on campus. Yep, Worcester Hall is the architecture school. Sarah completed her master's there. Buildings like this are pretty pervasive across most American and Canadian campuses. Yeah, there was a big bulky concrete building on the campus where I went to college.
和他们的父母走过时说，讽刺的是，这里是建筑学院，而它却是校园里最丑的建筑。没错，伍斯特大厅就是建筑学院。莎拉在那里完成了她的硕士学位。像这样的建筑在美国和加拿大的大多数校园里都很普遍。是的，我上大学的校园里也有一座又大又笨重的混凝土建筑。
And I hated when I had to go through it. It just reminded me of a bunker or a bomb shelter. These big concrete buildings just like bum me out. Absolutely, I mean, it has these connotations of, you know, Soviet era construction, sometimes third world construction, all these negative associations. This is Professor Adrian Forty, author of the excellent book Concrete and Culture. He's been researching concrete for around ten years now. It has a bad name.
我讨厌不得不穿过它。它只会让我想起地堡或防空洞。这些巨大的混凝土建筑只会让我感到沮丧。当然，我的意思是，它带有苏联时代建筑的内涵，有时甚至是第三世界建筑的内涵，所有这些负面联想。这是阿德里安·福蒂（Adrian Forty）教授，他是那本优秀著作《混凝土与文化》（Concrete and Culture）的作者。他研究混凝土已经大约十年了。它名声不好。
Apart from aesthetic criticisms, concrete buildings present environmental concerns. A lot of these buildings built at a time when energy was cheap and they use up an awful lot of energy to heat and cool them. Concrete buildings were built with the illusion of plenty, that we will always have enough energy to build and heat and cool these massive, inefficient structures. As harsh as it looks, concrete is an utterly optimistic building material. Arguably too optimistic. Really from the 1920s it was seen as being the material that would change the world. It had the potential to build things in a way that hadn't been
除了审美上的批评，混凝土建筑还带来了环境问题。许多这类建筑建于能源廉价的时代，它们消耗了大量能源来供暖和制冷。混凝土建筑是在“资源充足”的幻觉下建造的，认为我们总会有足够的能源来建造、供暖和制冷这些巨大的、低效的结构。尽管看起来很严酷，但混凝土是一种极其乐观的建筑材料。可以说太乐观了。实际上，从20世纪20年代起，它就被视为一种将改变世界的材料。它有潜力以一种前所未有的方式建造事物。
seen before. Concrete was this material that seemed boundless, readily available in vast quantities, and it could create massive spaces, unlike any other material. So concrete sprang up everywhere. It's the second most heavily consumed product in the world. The only thing we consume more of than concrete is water. We use concrete for sidewalks, bridges, tunnels, and highways, and of course, for giant buildings. Whether we're talking about stadia or auditoria or condominia or gymnasia or planetaria. So historically, government programs all over the world loved concrete. Particularly in Soviet Russia, but also later in Europe, North America. It was used for welfare, welfare state projects.
混凝土这种材料似乎是无限的，可以大量供应，并且可以创造出其他任何材料都无法比拟的巨大空间。因此，混凝土到处涌现。它是世界上消费量第二大的产品。我们消费量超过混凝土的唯一东西就是水。我们用混凝土建造人行道、桥梁、隧道、高速公路，当然还有巨大的建筑。无论我们谈论的是体育场、礼堂、公寓、体育馆还是天文馆。因此，从历史上看，世界各地的政府项目都喜欢混凝土。特别是在苏联，后来也在欧洲和北美。它被用于福利国家项目。
Concrete presented the most efficient way to house huge numbers of people. And philosophically, it was seen as humble, capable, and honest. Concrete was just out there in all of its rough glory not hiding behind any paint or layers saying here I am love me or hate me and his concrete buildings came to signify humility honesty and integrity They were erected all over the world as housing projects courthouses schools churches hospitals and City halls you'll stand outside and a tour bus will go by and they'll be, well, ladies and gentlemen, voted the most ugliest building in the world, Boston City Hall. How do you compete with that? Chris Grimley is up against a lot, but he's trying to restore Boston City Hall's reputation.
混凝土提供了容纳大量人口的最有效方式。从哲学上讲，它被视为谦逊、能干且诚实的。混凝土以其粗犷的荣耀展现出来，不躲在任何油漆或涂层后面，仿佛在说：我就在这里，爱我也好，恨我也罢。他的混凝土建筑开始象征着谦逊、诚实和正直。它们在世界各地被竖立起来，作为住房项目、法院、学校、教堂、医院和市政厅。你站在外面，旅游巴士经过时，他们会说：“女士们先生们，这就是被评为世界上最丑建筑的波士顿市政厅。”你怎么能和那个竞争呢？克里斯·格里姆利（Chris Grimley）面临着很多困难，但他正试图恢复波士顿市政厅的声誉。
My name is Chris Grimley. I'm with my fellow heroic people, Mark Paznik and Michael Kubo. Chris, Mark, and Michael have embarked on what they call the heroic project, chronicling the concrete structures in and around Boston. Rather than referring to these concrete buildings as brutalists, they prefer the term heroic. Because like so many superheroes, these structures have the best most noble intentions, but are sorely misunderstood. Also, just generally, brutalism is a big broad label that gets used inconsistently in architecture.
我叫克里斯·格里姆利。我和我的英雄同伴马克·帕兹尼克（Mark Pasnik）和迈克尔·库博（Michael Kubo）在一起。克里斯、马克和迈克尔开展了他们所谓的“英雄项目”（Heroic Project），记录波士顿及其周边的混凝土结构。他们不称这些混凝土建筑为“粗野主义”，而是更喜欢“英雄”这个词。因为像许多超级英雄一样，这些结构有着最崇高、最美好的初衷，却被严重误解了。此外，总的来说，“粗野主义”是一个宽泛的标签，在建筑学中被不一致地使用。
People tend to disagree on one precise definition. The name brutalism also just sounds intense, even though it's not actually related to brutality. It comes from Beton Brute, which is a French term for raw concrete. In any case, to these guys, heroic feels like a better term, especially in Boston, where concrete architecture swooped in and saved the day. You have to situate Boston in late 50s, 1960s. It is America's first city. Well, it is America's most historic city.
人们往往对一个精确的定义存在分歧。粗野主义这个名字听起来也很强烈，尽管它实际上与残暴无关。它来自“Beton Brut”，这是一个法语词，意为“原始混凝土”。无论如何，对这些人来说，“英雄”感觉是一个更好的词，尤其是在波士顿，混凝土建筑曾挺身而出，拯救了局面。你必须把波士顿置于50年代末、60年代的背景下。它是美国的第一座城市。好吧，它是美国最具历史意义的城市。
Again, not really, but I get your point. And yet, it finds itself in the doldrums. Boston, like a lot of other American cities, was plagued by a loss of manufacturing jobs and white flight to the suburbs. And for decades, Boston had the highest property taxes in the nation, and almost no development. There is this recognition from civic authorities that something needs to be done, and something needs to be done quickly.
再说一次，并不完全是，但我明白你的意思。然而，它发现自己处于低迷状态。波士顿像许多其他美国城市一样，受到制造业工作岗位流失和白人逃往郊区的困扰。几十年来，波士顿的房产税在全国最高，几乎没有任何发展。市政当局认识到必须采取行动，而且必须迅速采取行动。
So Boston sets an agenda to make the city great again with big, soaring, capable, thoroughly modern buildings made, of course, out of concrete. And though some of these buildings were celebrated, others were really not. What we call the third rail of Boston concrete modernism is city hall. These buildings were celebrated. Others were really not. When Boston City Hall was built in 1968, critics were put off by this concrete style. It was called alienating and cold. And since it was a government building, this criticism
因此，波士顿制定了一项议程，通过宏大、高耸、能干、彻底现代化的建筑——当然是由混凝土制成的——让城市再次伟大。虽然其中一些建筑受到了赞誉，但另一些却真的没有。我们称之为波士顿混凝土现代主义“第三轨道”的是市政厅。这些建筑受到了赞誉。另一些却真的没有。当波士顿市政厅于1968年建成时，评论家们对这种混凝土风格感到反感。它被称为疏离和冰冷。由于它是政府建筑，这种批评
became impossible to remove from politics. Boston City Hall became a political pawn. Mayors and City Council members kept trying to win public support with promises to get rid of the building, like John Tobin did when he ran for City Council. Hi everybody, this is John Tobin. Thanks for visiting votejontobin.com. Here we are on City Hall Plaza in front of Boston City Hall. I'm not in our context, but I know bad I could actually want to see it. This is a bad building, and I think we can do a lot by knocking this building down.
变得无法从政治中剥离。波士顿市政厅成了政治棋子。市长和市议会议员不断试图通过承诺拆除该建筑来赢得公众支持，就像约翰·托宾（John Tobin）竞选市议员时所做的那样。大家好，我是约翰·托宾。感谢访问votejontobin.com。我们现在在波士顿市政厅前的市政厅广场。我不在我们的背景中，但我知道坏处，我真的想看到它。这是一座糟糕的建筑，我认为通过拆除这座建筑，我们可以做很多事情。
Former Mayor Thomas Manino actually started a study to really look into tearing it down. It turned out as a result of the study that you would need something like a nuclear grade weapon, basically to destroy this building, because it was so heavily over-bilted concrete. And so, when they couldn't tear down City Hall, officials chose to ignore it. People that occupied the building for decades and decades didn't like it, and so they didn't
前市长托马斯·梅尼诺（Thomas Menino）实际上启动了一项研究，真正考虑拆除它。研究结果表明，你基本上需要某种核武器级别的武器才能摧毁这座建筑，因为它是由极其厚重的混凝土建造的。因此，当他们无法拆除市政厅时，官员们选择了忽视它。几十年来占据这座建筑的人们不喜欢它，所以他们没有
invest money into the building, and effectively wanted to see the building go away. This is called active neglect, and it happens with a lot of concrete buildings. They are intentionally unrepaired, unrenovated, and uncared for. Which only makes the building more ugly, and then more hated, and then more ignored, and creates this vicious cycle where the public hate of Boston City Hall feeds itself. And then the discussion years on really became about what the original architects had done wrong, as if this were not a failure of maintenance, but a failure of the initial design. When people built these mammoth concrete structures, no one really thought about maintenance.
投入资金维护这座建筑，实际上希望看到这座建筑消失。这被称为“主动忽视”，这种情况在许多混凝土建筑中都会发生。它们被故意不修理、不翻新、不照料。这只会让建筑变得更丑，然后更被憎恨，然后更被忽视，从而形成一种恶性循环，公众对波士顿市政厅的憎恨助长了自身。随后的讨论真正变成了关于最初的建筑师做错了什么，仿佛这不是维护的失败，而是最初设计的失败。当人们建造这些巨大的混凝土结构时，没有人真正考虑过维护。
They seemed indestructible. In the early days of concrete, people assumed that this was an everlasting material that wouldn't need any attention at all. And that's wrong. We know that it does need to be looked after. It does deteriorate. It does decay. But it can be hard to tell when concrete is decaying. If you think of brick and timber, the decay takes place on the surface of them. But with concrete, the deterioration is internal. Concrete deteriorates chemically from the inside out.
它们看起来坚不可摧。在混凝土的早期，人们认为这是一种永恒的材料，根本不需要任何关注。那是错误的。我们知道它确实需要被照料。它确实会恶化。它确实会腐烂。但很难判断混凝土何时在腐烂。如果你想到砖块和木材，腐烂发生在它们的表面。但对于混凝土，恶化是内部的。混凝土从内到外发生化学恶化。
Part of this has to do with the metal reinforcements that help hold up most concrete buildings. The rebar, well it can rust, and the rust eats away at the overall structure. But Adrian 40 says tearing them down is not the answer. Because as soon as you tell them down, then you have a problem, first of all, what you do with a detritus that's left.
部分原因与帮助支撑大多数混凝土建筑的金属加固物有关。钢筋，嗯，它会生锈，锈迹会侵蚀整个结构。但阿德里安·福蒂说，拆除它们不是答案。因为一旦你拆除它们，你首先就会遇到一个问题：你如何处理留下的残骸？
And secondly, you've got to replace them with something else and use up a whole lot more energy and create a lot more CO2 in building something in that place. They already used up all that energy when they were made. They're already there. We can adapt these buildings to make them greener and make them more appealing places to be by adding windows, for example. But basically, Professor Forty thinks
其次，你必须用其他东西替换它们，并消耗更多的能源，在那个地方建造东西时产生更多的二氧化碳。它们在制造时已经消耗了所有那些能源。它们已经存在了。我们可以改造这些建筑，通过增加窗户等方式，使它们更环保，使它们成为更具吸引力的地方。但基本上，福蒂教授认为
we can all develop the capacity to love these concrete broods in all their hulking glory. Yeah, sure, people can learn to love anything. But, you know, as with any art form, whether it's opera or painting or literature, the more you know about it, the more you'll get out of it, the more you'll appreciate it. And this is especially true of concrete buildings. Architecture students appreciate them because they know that concrete actually requires a hell of a lot of skill and finesse to work with. To do architecture in concrete is proof that you are really an architect. It's the test of being an architect. For the concrete building, every little detail needs to be calculated in advance.
我们都可以培养出爱上这些混凝土建筑及其笨重荣耀的能力。是的，当然，人们可以学会爱上任何东西。但是，你知道，正如任何艺术形式一样，无论是歌剧、绘画还是文学，你了解得越多，你从中得到的就越多，你就会越欣赏它。对于混凝土建筑尤其如此。建筑系学生欣赏它们，因为他们知道混凝土实际上需要极高的技巧和精细度才能使用。用混凝土进行建筑是证明你确实是一名建筑师的证据。这是成为建筑师的考验。对于混凝土建筑，每一个小细节都需要提前计算。
Concrete is wildly intimidating to work with. Once you pour it, there's no going back. With a concrete building, it's like the result of an immaculate conception. The whole thing is an integral monolithic whole, and it has to be right. And aside from the interesting design challenges that poses, concrete itself as a material can be subtly beautiful if you look closely. You know what we think of is just a monolithic, consistent homogenous texture is actually really rich and has a lot of interest when you actually go up to it and consider it.
混凝土在操作上非常令人畏惧。一旦你浇筑了它，就没有回头路了。对于混凝土建筑，它就像是圣母受孕的结果。整个东西是一个完整的整体，它必须是正确的。除了它带来的有趣设计挑战外，如果你仔细观察，混凝土本身作为一种材料可以微妙地美丽。你知道，我们认为只是单调、一致、均匀的纹理，实际上非常丰富，当你真正走近它并考虑它时，它有很多趣味。
Sarah Briggs Ramsey, the one I spoke with at Berkeley's Worcester Hall, did a year-long project traveling around the world, looking at concrete buildings in Europe and Asia and south and North America. To create a global comparison of one material that I think is so sort of under-considered, it's like the background of all the cities, but no one actually stands to look. We call the city a concrete jungle to talk about the artificialness of the urban landscape, but concrete can actually be a very natural expression of the environment. Concrete's color and texture can be dictated by local climate, local earth, and local rock. This is the Harvard Science Center on the Harvard campus, and it's got a very purpley, like a really pronounced purpley color, and that's the ground from the site.
莎拉·布里格斯·拉姆齐，就是我在伯克利伍斯特大厅采访的那位，做了一个为期一年的项目，环游世界，观察欧洲、亚洲、南美和北美的混凝土建筑。为了创造一种材料的全球比较，我认为这种材料被低估了，它就像所有城市的背景，但没有人真正停下来看。我们称城市为“混凝土丛林”来谈论城市景观的人工性，但混凝土实际上可以是环境的一种非常自然的表达。混凝土的颜色和纹理可以由当地气候、当地土壤和当地岩石决定。这是哈佛校园里的哈佛科学中心，它有一种非常紫色的、非常明显的紫色，那就是来自现场的土壤。
Concrete can also be an expression of local style and custom, like how UK concrete has big, thick, textured chunks of rock, while Japanese concrete is very fine and custom. Like how UK concrete has big thick textured chunks of rock, while Japanese concrete is very fine and flat. But the beauty of concrete architecture is all the better when you can just observe the buildings like pieces of sculpture, without actually having to live and work in them, which brings in concrete surprising ally, photography. Concrete looks good in photographs. It provides this kind of neutral background.
混凝土也可以是当地风格和习俗的表达，比如英国的混凝土有大块、厚实、有纹理的岩石，而日本的混凝土非常精细和定制。比如英国的混凝土有大块厚实的岩石，而日本的混凝土非常精细和平坦。但混凝土建筑的美感在你可以像观察雕塑一样观察建筑时会更好，而不必真正住在里面和在里面工作，这引入了混凝土令人惊讶的盟友：摄影。混凝土在照片中看起来很好。它提供了这种中性的背景。
It provides a wonderful setting for people's skin tones, color of their clothes. Fashion photographers realize this first and then pockets of the internet started to appreciate these concrete buildings. There are lots of these blogs and so on, which show a kind of extraordinary enthusiasm for concrete. Photography is allowing a new audience of non-architects to appreciate these buildings for their strong lines, their crisp shadows, and increasingly, the ideal is in the embody. They represent a set of ideas about the state of the world and what the future was imagined to be.
它为人们的肤色、衣服的颜色提供了绝佳的衬托。时尚摄影师首先意识到了这一点，然后互联网上的各个角落开始欣赏这些混凝土建筑。有很多这样的博客等等，它们展示了对混凝土的一种非凡的热情。摄影正在让非建筑师的新受众欣赏这些建筑的强劲线条、清脆的阴影，以及日益体现的理想。它们代表了一套关于世界状态以及未来被想象成什么样的想法。
We want to preserve. We should remember what people were thinking 50 years ago. If we tear these buildings down, we will lose all of that. Architecture, whether we want to admit it or not, has a sort of shelf life, a time after which buildings fall out of fashion, and then are allowed to fall apart. Back in the 1960s, Victorian-style buildings were considered hideous, falling apart, impossible to repair, and we were tearing batches of them down, all the while erecting big concrete buildings. But enough Victorians were saved that today they are these beautiful, lovingly restored
我们想要保护。我们应该记住50年前人们在想什么。如果我们拆除这些建筑，我们将失去所有这些。建筑，无论我们是否愿意承认，都有一定的保质期，在那之后建筑会过时，然后被允许分崩离析。早在20世纪60年代，维多利亚风格的建筑被认为是丑陋的、分崩离析的、无法修复的，我们拆除了成批的它们，同时竖立起巨大的混凝土建筑。但足够多的维多利亚建筑被保存了下来，以至于今天它们成了这些美丽的、被精心修复的
treasures. Brutalist, heroic, whatever you want to call it. Concrete architecture now finds itself at a potential inflection point. Too outdated to be modern, too young to be classic. In a small but growing band of architects, architecture enthusiasts and preservationists would like us to just wait a bit and see. Maybe with a little time and love we might discover some architectural diamonds in the rough that we just can't see right now.
宝藏。粗野主义、英雄主义，无论你想怎么称呼它。混凝土建筑现在发现自己处于一个潜在的转折点。太老旧而无法成为现代，太年轻而无法成为经典。在一小群但不断壮大的建筑师、建筑爱好者和保护主义者中，他们希望我们稍等片刻，拭目以待。也许随着一点时间和爱，我们可能会发现一些我们现在无法看到的粗糙中的建筑钻石。
Michael McKinnell, architect of Boston City Hall, died of a COVID related illness at the age of 84. He is survived by his wife and architectural partner, Stephanie Malice. Our heart goes out to all who knew him and loved him. After the break, we honor a true vanguard of architectural criticism, Michael Sorkin. Stay with us. In late March, we also lost designer and architecture critic, Michael Sorkin, two complications brought on by COVID-19. When he started writing for the village voice in the 1980s, he brought a totally
波士顿市政厅的建筑师迈克尔·麦金内尔死于与新冠相关的疾病，享年84岁。他的妻子兼建筑合伙人斯蒂芬妮·马利斯（Stephanie Malice）健在。我们向所有认识他并爱他的人表示慰问。休息之后，我们将纪念一位真正的建筑评论先锋，迈克尔·索金（Michael Sorkin）。请留下来。3月下旬，我们还失去了设计师和建筑评论家迈克尔·索金，死于新冠肺炎引发的并发症。当他在20世纪80年代开始为《乡村之声》（Village Voice）撰稿时，他带来了一种完全
new kind of approach to writing about buildings, one that focused on people and politics. I feel like he really stretched the boundaries on, you know, how confrontational you could be in print. This is architecture critic at Curbden, in front of the show, Alexander Lang. Storkin became famous for ripping into conventional wisdom and sometimes ripping into important builders and other critics too. It gave a vitality to architecture criticism and stretched the boundaries of what it could be
新的关于建筑写作的方法，一种专注于人和政治的方法。我觉得他真的拓宽了你在印刷品中可以有多么对抗的界限。这是《Curbden》的建筑评论家，节目主持人亚历山大·朗（Alexander Lang）。索金因抨击传统智慧，有时也抨击重要的建筑师和其他评论家而闻名。它为建筑评论注入了活力，并拓宽了它可能成为什么的界限，
in a way that really kind of brought it to a new generation's attention and has continued to be really important for younger critics. Michael Sorkin wrote about buildings, but also the much bigger factors that make up an urban landscape. You know, one of the things that comes through really strongly in his work is this idea that it's not, architecture isn't just this pure profession of, you know, mostly men, you know, thinking about forms and then placing them in the city. You know, architecture is something that is shaped by social change, political change, dirty money, all of these things, and Sorkin always really brought that into the mix. In 2009, Sorkin published a book called 20 Minutes in Manhattan, which traces the walk
以一种真正引起新一代关注的方式，并继续对年轻评论家非常重要。迈克尔·索金不仅写建筑，还写构成城市景观的更大因素。你知道，在他的作品中非常强烈地体现出来的一点是，建筑不仅仅是这种纯粹的职业，你知道，主要是男人，你知道，思考形式然后把它们放在城市里。你知道，建筑是由社会变革、政治变革、肮脏的钱、所有这些东西塑造的，而索金总是真正把这些带入其中。2009年，索金出版了一本名为《曼哈顿20分钟》（20 Minutes in Manhattan）的书，追踪了从
from his home to his studio in New York. Sorkin wrote about paying special, close attention to the little details of his neighborhood, and how those small details taught him so much about history and community. It's the kind of book that 99% of visible listeners would love, and it feels especially relevant right now. The kind of attention that he was paying to that part
他家到他在纽约工作室的步行路程。索金写到了特别关注他社区的小细节，以及这些小细节如何教会了他关于历史和社区的很多东西。这是《99%隐形》听众会喜欢的那种书，而且它现在感觉特别相关。他对他城市那部分所付出的那种关注
of his city is something that we all can do now. I mean, people are obviously feeling stir crazy in their homes, but if they're also feeling stir crazy in their neighborhoods, one way to get over it is to add another layer of attention or go down streets that you don't normally go down. And I feel like that 20-minute limit could actually be a little form of freedom if you really want to drill down and think about your neighborhood in a deeper way than you usually do because
是我们现在所有人都可以做到的。我的意思是，人们显然在家里感到坐立不安，但如果他们在社区里也感到坐立不安，克服它的一种方法是增加另一层关注，或者走你通常不走的街道。我觉得那20分钟的限制实际上可以成为一种小小的自由，如果你真的想深入挖掘并以比平时更深的方式思考你的社区，因为
you're rushing through it to go somewhere else. A lot of Michael Sworken's writing is not online, but one of the pieces that made the rounds a couple of times on the internet was a provocative, meditative list called 250 things an architect should know. I thought it would be nice to read some of it now. Some selections from 250 things in architecture. No. The feel of cool marble under bear feet.
你正匆忙穿过它去别的地方。迈克尔·索金的很多文章都没有在线，但互联网上流传过几次的一篇文章是一份挑衅性的、沉思的清单，名为《建筑师应该知道的250件事》。我想现在读一些会很好。选自《建筑师应该知道的250件事》。不。赤脚踩在凉爽大理石上的感觉。
How to live in a small room with five strangers for six months. With the same strangers in a lifeboat for a week, the distance a shout carries in the city, the distance of a whisper. The number of people with rent subsidies in New York City, in your town, include the rich. The flowering season for Azaleas. The flowering season for azaleas. The insulating properties of glass, the history of its production and use, and of its meaning. How to lay bricks. Would Victor Hugo really meant by this will kill that.
如何在六个月内与五个陌生人住在一个小房间里。与同样的陌生人在救生艇上待一周，城市中喊声传播的距离，耳语的距离。纽约市、你所在城镇的租金补贴人数，包括富人。杜鹃花的花期。杜鹃花的花期。玻璃的绝缘性能、其生产和使用的历史，以及它的意义。如何铺砖。维克多·雨果真正想表达的是“这将杀死那个”。
The rate at which the sea is arising, building information modeling, BIM, the energy embodied in aluminum, how to turn a corner, how to design a corner, how to sit in a corner. Now Antony Gaudi modeled the Sagrada Familia and calculated its structure. The rate at which that carpet you specified off gases. The migratory patterns of warblers and other seasonal travelers. The basics of mud construction. The direction of prevailing winds. Hydrology is destiny.
海平面上升的速度，建筑信息模型（BIM），铝中蕴含的能量，如何转弯，如何设计角落，如何坐在角落里。安东尼·高迪如何模拟圣家堂并计算其结构。你指定的那个地毯散发气体的速度。莺和其他季节性候鸟的迁徙模式。泥土建筑的基础。盛行风的方向。水文学就是命运。
Jane Jacobs in and out. Elementary ergonomics. The color wheel. What the client wants. What the client thinks it wants. What the client needs. What the client can afford. What the planet can afford.
简·雅各布斯（Jane Jacobs）的进进出出。基础人体工程学。色轮。客户想要什么。客户认为它想要什么。客户需要什么。客户负担得起什么。地球负担得起什么。
The theoretical basis for modernity and a great deal about its factions and inflections. What the brick really wants. What went wrong in Provid Igo? What went wrong with the Tacoma Nero's Bridge? Where the CCTV cameras are. The secrets of the success of Robert Moses. The reciprocal influences of Chinese and Japanese building. the proper proportions of a gin martini, how the crow flies, how the pyramids were built, why, the pleasures of the suburbs, the horrors,
现代性的理论基础及其许多派系和变体。砖块真正想要什么。普鲁伊特-伊戈（Pruitt-Igoe）出了什么问题？塔科马海峡大桥出了什么问题？闭路电视摄像头在哪里。罗伯特·摩西（Robert Moses）成功的秘密。中日建筑的相互影响。金马天尼的适当比例，乌鸦如何飞行，金字塔是如何建造的，为什么，郊区的乐趣，恐怖，
the quality of light passing through ice, the meaninglessness of borders, the reasons for their tenacity, the need for freaks, is possible to begin designing anywhere, the smell of concrete after rain, the angle of the sun at the equinox, how to ride a bicycle, the depth of the aquifer beneath you, the slope of a handicapped ramp, the wages of construction workers, where materials come from, how to get lost. The pattern of artificial light at night, seen from space. The reasons for the split between architecture and engineering,
光线穿过冰的质量，边界的无意义，它们顽固的原因，对怪胎的需求，从任何地方开始设计都是可能的，雨后混凝土的味道，春分时太阳的角度，如何骑自行车，你下方含水层的深度，残疾人坡道的坡度，建筑工人的工资，材料来自哪里，如何迷路。从太空看到的夜间人造光模式。建筑与工程分裂的原因，
many ideas about what constitutes utopia would shop safety, the architectural impact of colonialism on the cities of North Africa, a distaste for imperialism, the history of Beijing. Dutch domestic architecture in the 17th century, the rate at which copper acquires a patina. The levels of particulates in the air of Tianjin, the capacity of white pine trees to sequester carbon, the fire code, the seismic code, the health code. How to listen closely. That there is a big danger in working in a single medium. The log jam you don't even know your stuck in will be broken by a shift in representation. How to escape a maze.
关于什么是乌托邦的许多想法，车间安全，殖民主义对北非城市建筑的影响，对帝国主义的厌恶，北京的历史。17世纪的荷兰住宅建筑，铜获得铜绿的速度。天津空气中的颗粒物水平，白松树固碳的能力，消防规范，抗震规范，卫生规范。如何仔细倾听。在单一媒介中工作有很大的危险。你甚至不知道自己陷入的僵局将被表现形式的转变所打破。如何逃离迷宫。
Quirty. The proper way to behave with interns. The history of big machines, including those that can fly. How to calculate ecological footprints, three good lunch spots within walking distance, the value of human life, who pays, who profits, what to refuse to do, even for the money. The fine print in the contract, a smattering of naval architecture. Barrio practices in a wide range of cultures. The density needed to support a pharmacy.
古怪。与实习生相处的正确方式。大机器的历史，包括那些能飞的机器。如何计算生态足迹，步行距离内三个不错的午餐地点，生命的价值，谁支付，谁获利，即使为了钱也要拒绝做什么。合同中的细则，略知海军建筑。各种文化中的贫民窟做法。支持药房所需的密度。
The density needed to support a subway, the effect of the design of your city on food miles for fresh produce. Squatter settlements via visits and conversations with residents. The history and techniques of architectural representation across cultures. A bit of chemistry and physics. The importance of the Amazon. How to patch leaks. The components of a comfortable environment for sleep.
支持地铁所需的密度，你城市的设计对新鲜农产品食品里程的影响。通过与居民的访问和交谈了解棚户区。跨文化建筑表现的历史和技术。一点化学和物理知识。亚马逊的重要性。如何修补泄漏。舒适睡眠环境的组成部分。
Strengths of materials, if only intuitively. Why do you think architecture does any good? The depreciation cycle. What rusts? Good model making techniques in wood and cardboard. How to play a musical instrument. The acoustic properties of trees and shrubs. How to guard a house from floods.
材料强度，即使只是直觉上的。你认为建筑有什么好处吗？折旧周期。什么会生锈？木材和纸板的良好模型制作技术。如何演奏乐器。树木和灌木的声学特性。如何保护房屋免受洪水侵袭。
How to give directions. Offic floods, how to give directions, efficiently, and courteously. How close is too close? Bicycle safety and etiquette. The acoustic performance of Boston Symphony Hall, how to open the window, the diameter of the earth, the number of gallons of water used in a shower. The distance at which you can recognize faces. How and when do bribe public officials for the greater good? Concrete finishes. Straw-Bale building technology.
如何指路。洪水，如何高效、礼貌地指路。多近才算太近？自行车安全和礼仪。波士顿交响大厅的声学表现，如何打开窗户，地球的直径，淋浴时使用的加仑水量。你能识别面孔的距离。为了更大的利益，如何以及何时贿赂公职人员？混凝土饰面。草捆建筑技术。
Rachel Carson. Your neighbors. The remediation capacity of wetlands. The capacity of wetlands to attenuate storm searches, the depths of desire, the heights of folly, the golden, and other ratios. Those are selections from 250 things an architect should know by Michael Sorkin. He died on March 26, 2020, from COVID. He was the head of the Michael Sorkin Studio and president of Terraform, a non-profit research group.
蕾切尔·卡森（Rachel Carson）。你的邻居。湿地的修复能力。湿地减缓风暴潮的能力，欲望的深度，愚蠢的高度，黄金比例和其他比例。以上是迈克尔·索金所著《建筑师应该知道的250件事》的节选。他于2020年3月26日死于新冠。他是迈克尔·索金工作室的负责人，也是非营利研究小组Terraform的总裁。
He is survived by his wife Joan Cope Check. She is a professor of modern culture and media at Brown University. We send her our sincere condolences and thank her for giving us permission to air Michael Sorkin's writing. 99% of visible was produced this week by Avery Trouffleman and Chris Baroubae, music by Sean Rial. Katie Mingle is the senior producer of Kurt Coles Dayly is the digital director. The rest of the crew is senior editor Delaney Hall, Joe Rosenberg, Sophia Klatsker, Sharif Yusuf, Emmett Fitzgerald, Vivian Leigh, and me Roman Mars. We are a project of 9.7K ALW in San Francisco and produced on Radio Row, which is distributed in multiple locations throughout the East Bay, but in our heart it will always be.
他的妻子琼·科普切克（Joan Cope Check）健在。她是布朗大学现代文化与媒体教授。我们向她表示诚挚的慰问，并感谢她允许我们播出迈克尔·索金的文章。《99%隐形》本周由艾弗里·特鲁夫曼和克里斯·巴鲁贝（Chris Baroubae）制作，音乐由肖恩·里亚尔（Sean Rial）创作。凯蒂·明格尔（Katie Mingle）是高级制片人，库尔特·科尔斯·戴利（Kurt Coles Daily）是数字总监。其余工作人员包括高级编辑德莱尼·霍尔（Delaney Hall）、乔·罗森伯格（Joe Rosenberg）、索菲亚·克拉茨克（Sophia Klatsker）、谢里夫·优素福（Sharif Yusuf）、埃米特·菲茨杰拉德（Emmett Fitzgerald）、薇薇安·李（Vivian Leigh）和我，罗曼·马尔斯。我们是旧金山9.7K ALW的一个项目，在Radio Row制作，在东湾的多个地点分发，但在我们心中，它永远是。
In beautiful, downtown, Oakland, California. We are a proud founding member of Radio Topia from PRX, a fiercely independent collective of the most innovative listener-supported podcasts in the world. Find more at radiotopia.fm. You can find the show and enjoy discussion about the show on Facebook. You can tweet me at Roman Mars and the show at 99PI org. We're on Instagram and Reddit too. But our forever home on the web is 99PI.org. Radio Tapio from PRX. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
在美丽的加利福尼亚州奥克兰市中心。我们是来自PRX的Radio Topia的骄傲创始成员，这是一个由世界上最具创新性的听众支持的播客组成的激烈独立的集体。在radiotopia.fm了解更多信息。你可以在Facebook上找到该节目并享受关于该节目的讨论。你可以在推特上关注我@RomanMars，关注节目@99PIorg。我们也在Instagram和Reddit上。但我们在网上的永久家园是99PI.org。来自PRX的Radio Topia。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。